nos encontramos con el ministro de salud
el doctor víctor díaz con muchísimas
gracias por estar con nosotros en france
24 gracias por la invitación y empecemos
hablando sobre la situación del sistema
de salud en ucrania después de estos
meses de guerra la situación en el
sistema de salud es bastante compleja y
esto es resultado de la invasión a gran
escala de la federación rusa a nuestro
país
con una invasión lo que es importante
recordar no ha sido provocada y rusia se
comporta como un país terrorista y ahora
todas las convenciones posibles incluida
la convención de ginebra
dispara a la población civil y destruye
una infraestructura civil
después de casi cinco meses de la
invasión rusia ha dañado más de 800
establecimientos de salud
127 fueron completamente destruidos y es
imposible restaurar los
para reconstruirlos necesitamos una
inversión de 32.000 millones krishnas
que es alrededor de 1000 millones de
dólares estadounidenses
para la mente de las farmacias están
colapsando
más de 500 han sufrido daños y más de
100 no han podido repararse necesitamos
construirlas de nuevo esto limita el
acceso de las personas a medicamentos
que salvan vidas
y rusia también destruye a ambulancias
más de 85 han resultado dañadas por
disparos proyectiles y otros
unos 150 automóviles fueron incautados
por terroristas y no sabemos su destino
posterior
y
todo esto afecta a la accesibilidad de
la atención médica y la forma en que
funcionan los centros de salud al mismo
tiempo la carga de los hospitales en
cuanto a la recepción de pacientes con
lesiones y politraumatismos ha aumentado
significativamente
cuando un proyectil golpea un edificio
residencial una gran cantidad de
personas resultan heridas estas son
llevadas a hospitales con heridas de
bala y todo esto lleva a que los
hospitales operen principalmente como
departamentos de cirugía traumatológica
los ataques cardíacos y los derrames
cerebrales también aumentan con la
guerra con otro aspecto que nos sigue
preocupando es el coronavirus y también
nos estamos preparando para un posible
aumento de casos
las organizaciones internacionales
especialmente las naciones unidas han
hablado
269 hospitales y centros de salud que
han sido atacados por las fuerzas rusas
cuál es la situación en esos y cuáles
son las cifras que tiene el gobierno
ucraniano
cuando la organización mundial de la
salud y otras organizaciones hablan de
ataques a centros de salud se refieren a
aquellas instituciones que pueden
verificar personalmente
pero las organizaciones internacionales
no ingresan a la zona de combate y no
ingresan a territorios donde rusia está
tratando de establecer un régimen de
ocupación
nosotros como ministerio de salud
recibimos información de estos
territorios también durante el periodo
de hostilidades
hoy estamos hablando de el hecho de que
los rusos mataron a 13 trabajadores
médicos y 48 resultaron gravemente
heridos
pero estas son cifras relacionadas con
médicos civiles a las que podemos
acceder
entendemos también que este número puede
ser mayor ya que una gran cantidad de
médicos civiles han sido reclutados en
las fuerzas armadas de ucrania porque
ayudan a nuestros militares que
defienden la frontera de nuestro país y
hay una gran cantidad de médicos hoy
cuyo destino aún no
se consideran desaparecidos porque no se
ha identificado donde podrían estar en
este momento
estos son todos nuevamente los
resultados de la agresión sin sentido de
la federación rusa hablemos un poco de
toda esta región del este del país en
kharkiv y en el donbass especialmente
donde esos hospitales han sido atacados
cuál es la situación en este momento de
esos centros y el personal de salud
quiero enfatizar que el problema no es
con el gobierno de ucrania
el problema está en la federación rusa
porque por alguna razón transferimos las
consecuencias de la invasión sin sentido
de la invasión rusa a otros
es necesario entender que la catástrofe
humanitaria es causada por el hecho de
que la federación rusa ha invadido
nuestro país y está bombardeando
nuestras ciudades y hospitales
[Música]
por eso tenemos un acceso limitado
en algunas regiones no hay ningún acceso
para el suministro de medicamentos al
territorio de rusia y está tratando de
establecer un régimen de ocupación
y esto sucede en la región de gerson en
el sur de la región esa orilla en la
región de donges que en la región de
lugansk y en la región de jarque
cuál es la situación del personal médico
en estas zonas son bastante alejadas hay
bastante poco acceso especialmente para
llevar medicinas cuál es el trabajo del
ministro para apoyarlos allí
también tenemos algunos problemas en el
sur
es consecuencia de las acciones de rusia
que nosotros
el gobierno de ucrania no podamos
entregar medicamentos
hay un desastre humanitario como
resultado de que hay una agresión
injustificada
no podemos entenderlo
en cuanto a los territorios que se han
recuperado del control ruso ya hemos
comenzado nuestra actividad y hemos
proporcionado medicamentos a todos
no está prestando atención médica en
algunos hospitales estaban parcialmente
destruidos por dueños
en lugares donde se encuentran
hospitales completamente destruidos
hemos habilitado otros espacios
lo importante es que disponibilidad de
atención médica en los territorios
recuperados está hoy asegurada y la
atención de emergencia llegada a todos
los rincones
el gran problema está en las regiones
donde hay hostilidades
así en primer lugar trabajan los médicos
militares
que brindan atención médica urgente a
todo aquel que la necesite
pero el acceso es limitado precisamente
porque estamos siendo bombardeados
constantemente
están bajo el fuego constante de cohetes
hay tiroteos continuos y sin sentido o
tiroteos intencionales de civiles
ucranianos
hablemos también de esos hospitales que
están en esas regiones donde están
ocupadas actualmente por las fuerzas
rusas pero son hospitales ucranianos el
personal que trabajaba allí es ucraniano
cuál es la relación de ustedes con ese
personal le siguen pagando salarios cómo
tratan a los pacientes cómo es esta
relación el gobierno de eugenia continúa
pagando salarios a todos los
trabajadores médicos que están y
trabajan en hospitales que se encuentran
en territorios donde la federación rusa
está tratando de establecer un régimen
de ocupación
tenemos acceso y comunicación con ellos
pero no en el volumen que había antes
del 24 de febrero
actualmente utilizamos diversos recursos
para apoyar a nuestros trabajadores
médicos y entregarles los medicamentos e
insumos necesarios
pero no funciona en todas partes
apelamos a todos los socios
internacionales la organización mundial
de la salud la cruz roja médicos sin
fronteras para presionar a la federación
rusa el país agresor para que cumpla la
convención sobre la protección de la
población civil en el tiempo y
proporcionar medicamentos verificados
con estricta política regulatoria
en hospitales ubicados en territorios
donde rusia está tratando de establecer
un régimen de ocupación
en los territorios donde no tenemos ese
acceso hay alrededor de 400
establecimientos de atención médica que
brindan asistencia y salvan la vida de
los ucranianos
pero entendemos que hay problemas de
acceso a ciertos medicamentos
hubo hechos registrados de que la
federación rusa exportó de nuestros
hospitales medicamentos costosos que
estaban destinados allí por ejemplo para
el tratamiento de accidentes
cerebrovasculares
en estas zonas alejadas de ucrania la
situación es bastante complicada para
evacuar a los pacientes cuál ha sido
toda esa logística que han puesto
ustedes en marcha para apoyar no
solamente a quienes son heridos en la
guerra sino a esa población que todavía
vive en esas regiones
el sistema de atención de la salud se
reorientó en función
tanto de la migración interna forzada de
ucranianos como de la migración externa
hoy tenemos un claro seguimiento de la
ocupación de camas quirúrgicas de perfil
terapéutico en el oriente centro y
occidente de nuestro país
entendemos las etapas y cómo evacuar a
los heridos a aquellos hospitales con
menor carga de trabajo donde se pueda
brindar asistencia médica
al mismo tiempo el programa de bakwa
mail trabaja con la comisión europea
gracias a este evacuamos a los heridos
graves para su tratamiento en hospitales
de países europeos
además de la ayuda de los estados unidos
de américa y canadá
estamos potencialmente negociando con
israel y australia para que también
estén dispuestos a aceptar ucranianos
gravemente enfermos y heridos para
brindar asistencia médica
bueno me gustaría agradecer a todos los
socios que ayudan a ucrania no solo en
el tratamiento de nuestros heridos en el
extranjero
sino también en la transferencia de
medicamentos productos y equipos médicos
al territorio de ucrania
lo que realmente nos ayuda para
oponernos a la agresión armada
y a una invasión a gran escala de la
federación rusa en nuestro frente médico
ustedes experto en epidemias y tuvo a su
cargo aliviar el kobe 19 no se siente en
ucrania pero todavía continúa cuáles son
esas estrategias de ustedes todavía para
apoyar a la población y también para
evitar que sufran sucedan otras
epidemias u otros problemas de salud
especialmente en esas zonas donde la
gente no tiene agua no tiene gas lleva
meses viviendo en refugios subterráneos
bueno esta pregunta tiene dos
componentes primero una contramedida
contra kobe 19 y de hecho en los últimos
meses hemos visto una disminución en el
número de casos de enfermedad por
coronavirus en ucrania esto estaba
relacionado con la disminución general
de casos en el territorio de la región
europea y en principio no lo excluimos
con la restricción del acceso a los
diagnósticos de los ucranianos que
estaban principalmente preocupados por
salvar la vida y no por salvar la salud
porque era imposible salir a hacer la
prueba había constantes disparos de
cohetes y de artillería en ciertas
regiones de nuestro país con respecto a
la situación epidémica en ucrania en su
conjunto hoy es estable y controlada se
ha creado una red de centros de control
y prevención de enfermedades en ucrania
al comienzo de la guerra completamos los
reactivos necesarios y los sistemas de
pcr para monitorear o identificar
continuamente los patógenos de al menos
20 enfermedades infecciosas la
probabilidad de que ocurran es más alta
durante la guerra y controlamos estas
enfermedades
rastreamos y monitoreamos cólera para no
perderlo entre los casos de
gastroenterocolitis
monitoreamos tanto la poliomielitis como
otras infecciones controladas por
vacunas por lo tanto tratamos de
mantener la situación bajo control pero
entendemos que los brotes de
enfermedades infecciosas siempre ocurren
después de la guerra si el trauma
un gran número del personal médico bueno
parte ha quedado afectado herido por la
guerra y otros especialmente mujeres
salieron del país como consecuencia de
que tenían que evacuar a sus niños y
especialmente los momentos más difíciles
que como ha sido este trabajo para
reponer esa capacidad de personal médico
que ustedes no tienen y si se han
implementado una campaña para entrenar
más personas para apoyar en este campo
hoy en nuestro país el 100 por ciento
del financiamiento del programa de
garantía médica bajo el cual se
financian los establecimientos de salud
y el pago de salarios por parte del
estado se paga a los hospitales
esto es posible gracias a la ayuda que
recibimos de socios internacionales
la última ayuda es de un millón
setecientos mil dólares que los estados
unidos de américa transfirió al
presupuesto de ucrania como compensación
para los gastos incurridos por el estado
para cubrir el programa de garantía
médica
la unión europea y otros países socios
otorgan fondos adicionales al
presupuesto por lo que estamos muy
agradecidos ya que la economía de
ucrania no está funcionando como antes
por lo tanto necesitamos el apoyo y la
ayuda de socios internacionales no
podemos prescindir de ellos y apreciamos
mucho ese apoyo
los médicos y lo hemos visto en el
frente de batalla también han sido
héroes de esta guerra como aquellos que
han defendido el país con las armas así
que doctor muchísimas gracias